tu vois super ouais bah écoutes je vais
prendre
j'étais prendre des belles robes houcine
il est 8h30 au marché notre dame de
versailles romain lucas vient ici
plusieurs fois dans la semaine pour
étoffer la carte de son restaurant
ce qui retient particulièrement son
attention des produits frais locaux
prendre cette tradition passage obligé
ensuite chez un maraîcher bio choux
épinards ou encore comme couette que le
jeune chef cuisinera dans quelques
instants
c'est parti après le chargement effectué
direction le restaurant nuances à
quelques centaines de mètres du marché
un établissement que romain lucas
connaît bien puisqu'il y était en
apprentissage
après quelques expériences dans les
yvelines et à paris il décide il y a
huit mois d'acheter ce restaurant un
projet qui a un peu effrayé son
entourage malgré tout toujours présent à
ses côtés de l'année comme pour les
paquets
organisé on va dire au niveau des
papiers pour le linge tout près du
restaurant
il est 10 heures romain est en cuisine
des gestes précis qui lui ont notamment
été transmis par sa grand mère on a très
bien manger à moi et ma soeur est en
train de nous préparer des très bons
plats c'est vrai que sans forcément
participer tout le temps mais rien qu'en
la regardant s'arrêter assez passionnant
à voir
le restaurant propose une carte simple
mais qui change toutes les deux semaines
quatre entrées quatre plats quatre
desserts tout est élaboré dans cette
cuisine midi le service commence
[Musique]
le jeune chef cuisinier s'occupe des
plats chauds au menu ce midi noix de
veau accompagné de son écrasé de pommes
de terre et de sa sauce moutarde
je pense qu'une différence entre le
restaurateur et le cuisinier alors un
cuisinier va prendre le temps pour sa
cuisine il va transmettre quelque chose
dans l'assiette d'un restaurateur qui va
pas forcément faire du frais voilà
nourrit des personnes voilà moi pas
forcément l'objet pied je nourris mais
mais également voilà je transmets
quelque chose j'ai envie de transmettre
mon métier et ma passion dans mes
assiettes
romain n'officie pas seul dans son
restaurant il est assisté de thomas en
cuisine et de cédric pour le service en
salle
là un gars en or un patron compréhensif
et qui est prêt à laisser sa chance à
n'importe qui mais vraiment c'est
quelqu'un de bien un jeune chef
cuisinier qui vous l'aurez compris mise
avant tout sur la qualité des produits
présents dans les assiettes et qui met
tout en oeuvre pour réveiller vos
papilles gustatives